So yesterday the egg man called in and the
egg man says Biden will win Florida because
Trump lost his former home state of New York.
His home state is now Florida.
And old folks in Florida don't like Trump
and they like Biden.
Okay, that was the egg man yesterday.
Here's a different perspective with a shot
across the bow at the egg man saying it's
actually Trump who's going to win Florida.
Take a listen.
Yeah, I think Trump is going to win in Florida.
And the proof is.
Recently we tried to get legalization of marijuana
on the ballot and we couldn't even get 600000
signatures to get marijuana on the ballot.
And I know marijuana is way more popular.
Then Joe Biden is.
So, you know, there's not a lot of people
that vote Democratic or the system is heavily
rigged.
But yeah.
OK, so listen, cannabis in Florida.
I don't think that you can say that because
they couldn't get six hundred thousand signatures
for cannabis legalization in Florida.
It means Joe Biden is going to lose.
And in fact, there are lots.
Remember, Florida has the fifth oldest population
in the country.
There are lots of older folks in Florida who
have no interest in seeing marijuana legalized,
but they still are onboard with Joe Biden's
ideas rather than Donald Trump.
So my point is, I don't think we can glean
anything about the Florida presidential election
because of the failure of the cannabis signature
initiative.
That's my perspective right now.
We have a great program coming up on the bonus
show today.
We are going to talk about market manipulation
in terms of why we've seen the market do what
it is doing.
We will also talk about the fear that there
will be chaos if electoral electoral college
delegates are given free reign in the November
election.
And we will also talk about Paul Manafort,
former Trump campaign chairman Paul Manafort,
who is going to be spending a bunch of time
in prison.
He is being released to his home amid Corona
virus concerns.
How great for him.
By the way, what's happening with Michael
Cohen, though?
We'll talk about all of those stories and
more on today's bonus show.
Get instant access by becoming a member at
Join Packman dot com.